promised to protect our environment
we're getting it done the government has
made bold statements on climate change
hence the expectation this budget would
put significant building blocks in place
to deliver on its promise to make
Britain carbon neutral by 2050 instead
environmentalists say there were some
eye-catching measures but not enough to
make the transition towards a low-carbon
economy in his budget statement the
Chancellor announced plans for a plastic
packaging tax there's to be a tree
planting project to create a forest
bigger than Birmingham and funding for
flood defences will be doubled but other
measures will do little to tackle
climate change fuel duty has been frozen
for the tenth consecutive year 27
billion pounds will be spent on Road
building and overall there were no
significant announcements on large-scale
green infrastructure I think this budget
may have caused people to sober up a
little bit and think twice about whether
the government's rhetoric actually
matches its priorities but you know
let's let's wait and see what's actually
planned in the infrastructure
assessments in the next couple of months
but slightly on the face of it he didn't
flag anything that sounded particularly
green there was little in the budget to
help homeowners adjust towards a
low-carbon future on transport the
sector with the highest emissions there
were no major announcements on railway
improvements in the end the focus of
this budget was on the economy and of
course tackling coronavirus but there
was little sign of the leadership on
climate change which the government has
repeatedly promised Lisa Holland Sky
News